welcome back
spare us all we now know Prince Harry's
Memoir will be published on January the
10th and will feature a brooding picture
of him on the front and we'll be
entitled spare now I just want to read
you a little quote uh that's coming uh
sort of description by Harry uh about
the book I've worn many hats over the
years both literally and figuratively
figuratively excuse me
um My Hope Is that in telling my story
the highs and lows the mistakes the
Lessons Learned I can help show that no
matter where we come from we have more
in common than we think now that's a
perfectly nice sentiment a bit gooey a
bit American for British audience but a
very nice sentiment I I can't you know
you can't you can't I don't know yeah I
know but you wouldn't I feel kind of
diabetic after that
this is a book which he has been
reportedly paid for 36 million now we
don't know if that's true that's just a
reported figure in Hello magazine I
suspect it's slightly exaggerated but we
do know it's a very Hefty sum as he's
already said he's donating 1.2 million
pounds of it to go to charity now and
the rest to go into his pocket and if
you know anything about Publishers they
will not have agreed to this book just
being about Harry telling his now just
wait here here's truth
um I know you're squirming and feeling a
bit sick so we know there are going to
be elements of this book that are going
to prove highly controversial for the
royal family now I've always been a big
defender of Harry and Megan I am
slightly running out of steam so I just
we've got Diggy surprised you've lasted
this long
joining us now to discuss this literary
event of the century we have talk TV
contributor Paula Roan Adrian and Royal
author Dickie Arbiter thanks so much to
you both for joining us first of all
with you Dicky I mean this is this is
now primed to come out just before the
coronation what are the effects of that
what are the effects of it coming out
full stop uh I think it's a great
mistake he's just he's doing what his
dad did in 94. Jonathan dim will be
cooperating he's doing what his mum did
with Andrew Morton in 1992. why is he
bringing out a book he's obviously got a
lot on his chest that he wants to get
off
um unfortunately we saw part one with
the Oprah interview My Truth uh in which
the Queen lay Queen came out with that
wonderful one-liner Recollections may
vary and I think we'll find a lot in
this book where Recollections may vary I
think Dickie is interesting that you
bring up the fact that he's not the
first member of the royal family to um
or give an interview as you say that
that causes a lot of problem and I and I
I am concerned as someone who has
defended them in the past they they get
a they get a a very large degree of
hostility
um about anything they do but having
Harry must have seen the effect of
um his actions so far the Opera Oprah
interview I am slightly staggered after
the after the funeral where you saw it
it's very painful when families are
ripped apart and brothers are not
talking to each other do you think this
book was already in the process do you
think he might be regretting this he
might well be regretting it but uh it's
too late there were there was talk there
was speculation that he was asking for
changes now we heard uh how true it is
we don't know that he had signed off on
the book in summer Publishers are very
quick to press the button to run the
printing presses to get the book out in
the Autumn uh did he make the changes we
don't know what's he doing with the
money well we know that a million uh
pounds is going to send to Bali 300
000 pounds is going to uh Wellness uh
organization Vicky we're just going to
get Paula in here
what's your opinion how explosive do you
think this book is going to be or where
already we're we're doing exactly what
the Publishers want us to do which is
getting frightfully riled up before we
even read it and publicity too exactly
and really and truthfully what is it
that we don't know already
and I suspect that that's what's going
to happen I suspect we're going to get
this book which will be interesting we
will hear Harry's voice in the way no
doubt he wants us to but ultimately in
terms of the shock Factor I'm just not
sure we're there anymore I I think you
know what more have we got we've had
racism we've had mental health we have
had Oprah we've we've had Oprah we have
had the sad destruction of a loving
family you know we've had it where else
are we going to go with this well here's
the thing though in my experience a
publisher does not pay 36 million uh
dollars to get a reheated stuff they've
had before they will be saying you've
got to give us more they want the pound
the flesh that's my concern is even if
it's the odd paragraph in there and it
really aren't thousands of words could
be a lot more sort of self-help my truth
gobble but it only takes four paragraphs
saying something about it really
Pleasant about his father his upbringing
yeah the queen consort Yeah but whether
there's any truth in it that remains to
be seen well and and you know we've had
we've had numerous Bible sheets three
four of King Charles look we're not
going to hear anything new we don't need
to be excited I'm afraid I've got to
break in that's it from us peers are we
making as much anticipated return on
Monday